Natou 28 ans directeur de l'igou chudron
on a ouvert notre entreprise il y a 2
ans et demi maintenant on propose
essentiellement des glaces des repas
chauds des repas B froids on va dire des
assiettes de crêpe et on se on est sur
le point de proposer une carte de
samousa de sandwich restaurant on
accueille environ 80 personnes assises
on fait également de la vente à
l'emporté c'est-à-dire glace vacherin
bûche pour les périodes de fête nous
sommes actuellement deux salariés et moi
et ma femme 4 on travaille dans dans une
ambiance plutôt bon enfant avec le
sourire
et les amis viennent la famille tout le
monde est les bienvenus en fait on est
constamment en recherche de de personnel
de que ça soit en employé polyvalent en
extra ou en contrat à temps
plein on recherche souvent du personnel
et en général se base plutôt sur des
jeunes filles euh polyvalentes avec une
un minimum de dextérité aucune aucune
expérience requise on va dire vu que on
apprend tout sur sur le tas et si
expérience il a ça nous dérangerait pas
les missions à accomplir sont ce d'une
serveuse on va dire d'une serveuse de de
partout c'est-à-dire l'entretien des
locaux le service des glaces l'accueil
des clientèles la caisse
et voilà le poster pour avoir à partir
de 2015 un CDD avec un contrat d'avenir
si si demand
a le serveur ou la serveuse doit prendre
en charge la mise en place d'étable
gérer l'accueil des clients et
l'encaissement être capable d'assurer le
service faire preuve de
polyvalence
le petit conseil que je peux donner aux
futurs candidats qui vont venir ici
c'est d'avoir déjà une très bonne
présentation une
élocution une bonne élocution français
et également arriver avec minimum 5
minutes d'avance ça c'est c'est une
preuve de de
ponctualité